coming up next week at the Strasburg
plenary I pushed a good old scandals
kicked the curb for good as a food
origin labeling and unfair tax practices
come under the spotlight welcome to the
agenda it's an uncertain future for the
tens of thousands of refugees stranded
across Europe look at a common EU asylum
policy help ease some of their suffering
Europe has struggled in its efforts to
manage refugee flows I had to do a deal
with Turkey which was much criticized
but the countries on the front line and
our faith with larger numbers of asylum
applications as refugees trying to beat
being forced to leave Europe for turkey
in the future asylum claims me now not
to be handled by the country that a
refugee first arrives to any Peas vote
on the new commission proposal on
Wednesday we know that many of the
terrorist suspects have a criminal
background the European police force
takes one step closer to becoming bigger
and better to fight terrorism new powers
would allow Europol to set up
specialized counterterrorism units
increased powers are also being given a
step up efforts to counter cybercrime
any PS will give the new rules their
final seal of approval on Wednesday a
war has many stages the one against
multinationals and their tax avoidance
schemes has been hard fought but now the
attention turned towards member states
and their willingness to share
information on the big companies
operating in their playground plans also
in the pipeline to make the Commission
the middleman with access to any
information shared between national tax
authorities will and me pease agree that
members say should share corporate tax
returns and now for the news in brief
ending discrimination for mothers and
fathers with newborn babies on thursday
eps vote on a parental leaf initiative
traffic is benefits the tuna 730 billion
euros a year MVP's are calling on
members days to implement laws to better
protect women and children in particular
the horsemeat scandal may have long
passed for mep zara nuin course to make
country-of-origin labeling mandatory on
certain food products but is not just
meet they want it for milk too and they
have poles that suggest that eighty
eight percent of citizens back them for
meat and eighty-four percent unlock
labeling by the european commission has
so far not stepped up to propose
legislation on the issue stating costs
to be the factor a resolution will be
put to a vote on tuesday and that's all
we have this agenda take care and enjoy
the week
you